don't worry they have me under a
restraining order huh two of this year's
nominees Diane Keaton and Samantha
Morton have been here before the other
three Keisha castle Hughes and Charlize
Theron Naomi Watts are each enjoying
their first nominations the nominees for
performance by an actress and leading
role are Keisha castle Hughes in Whale
Rider Diane Keaton and something's got
to give
Samantha Morton you mean America
Charlize Theron in monster
Naomi Watts and 21 grams
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and the Oscar goes to Charlize Theron
[Applause]
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for Charlize Theron
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh this has been such an incredible year
I can't believe this
hey I don't have a lot of time I have to
thank my incredible director patty
Jenkins thank you thank you thank you
all of our producers brought Brad Clarke
Meighan mark
Donald Sammy Lee everybody at media 8
Bob and everybody at Newmarket
thank you so much for working so hard on
this film my incredible incredible
leading lady christina ricci who i
couldn't have done this film without you
are truly the unsung hero with this film
I have to thank our entire crew Tony G
for transforming me um so incredibly
every single person who worked on this
film I couldn't have done it without you
guys
incredible manager JJ Harris who have
represented me for so long now and
you've always believed in me I can't
thank you enough my friend Steve Warren
my lawyer thank you so much yes I know
he's my friend Heidi Shafer and Amanda
Silverman from pmk my guardian angel
best kono oh my producing partner Megan
Riley grant and if I'm forgetting
anybody please don't kill me and I know
everybody new zealand's Ben thanks so
I'm gonna thank everybody in South
Africa my home country
they're all watching tonight I'm
bringing this home next week and I have
to thank my incredible partner in crime
you're one hell of a partner to have
thank you so much for standing by me and
my mom you have sacrificed so much for
me to be able to live here and make my
dreams come true and there are no words
to describe how much I love you and I'm
not gonna cry thank you thank you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]